i want to start with congratulations i
watched your series i know i'm not
supposed to ask about certain things so
i'll
i'll be very guarded as i say this but
uh the thing about this series is it's
definitely unlike anything else that
i've seen
and i'm curious if that's what drew you
both to this material
yeah that's what we've both been saying
that we've kind of been through lockdown
and seen various versions of all the
stories on streamers and this felt like
wow this is a love story but it's got
you know so many other elements without
any spoilers and it's such a
mash of genres but ultimately it's a
it's an adult love story which i feel
like i personally don't get an
opportunity to read many adult stories
they're often you know
i don't know i really enjoyed this i
enjoyed reading it i enjoyed you know
researching the director and what a fun
wonderful storyteller he was and i've
always wanted to work with josh and this
is a fantastic character for me so it
was all uh all the boxes got ticked
similarly for me having worked with abe
on little monsters i sort of knew
how he likes to take
different tones in different genres and
smash them together and i love that
challenge you know every time he does it
he does it to such a unique effect where
it feels like
unlike anything else i've seen in any of
those spaces and this is a love story
unlike any other this is very unique and
different and very unexpected
i agree with that it's very hard to not
say uh yeah um
did she mention anything to you about
this when you were making little
monsters and asterisks if you've never
seen little monsters you really need to
see it movie's fantastic thank you man
uh no this came out of nowhere isla and
i during the pandemic were actually
talking about doing another project this
this rom-com that was really interesting
and this sort of fell into my lap um
with like a month before cameras were
gonna start rolling uh i i got the
scripts and was like wait what
um you want me to drop my everything in
the midst of a pandemic and go to
australia i don't know if i'm up for it
and i read the scripts
knew isla was in it and said uh just
when i think i'm out they pulled me back
in and went and it was
worth every minute because it was truly
an extraordinary process and
couldn't be prouder of of the work
i know that every actor likes to work a
different way some people like it to be
energized on set others are very much in
their head for both of you do you have a
similar work process like a yes we have
the same work process and so there was
absolutely
uh there that was what put it was so
comfortable right away i we both enjoy
making jokes between takes we're very
serious about our work i mean i speak
myself i'm very serious about my work i
do my research i put as many hours as
possible once i'm performing though i
like the atmosphere on set to be
just very
fun and light and you do too and i think
it was nice not to be kind of shocked or
like it was just nice we just we really
made jokes between we'd be crying in a
scene and then
right they yell cut and we're able to
laugh we we have the same language like
we we do we share sort of the same brain
and it was
especially on a show like this that
requires so many different things at all
times it's nice to decompress and just
laugh about the day yeah um and that was
really really great my favorite
experience shooting was we had this love
this this scene in episode two where we
have to essentially fall in love with
each other and um we were both so sick
like i mean just like a caricature of
sickness
and we we were on set
hocking up our lungs snotty and like no
covet but still like really bad colds
and it was just
such a pivotal scene and we were able to
get through it because
we just had each other's backs and
despite the fact that we were feeling
like garbage it was just a prime example
of how effortless the experience was of
this collaboration it truly was we just
we naturally and josh is just one of
those team partners he doesn't he is
just not competitive he's there for
everyone to win every other actor
everyone on set he knows their name he
cares about the process as much as a
result and so the journey is as great as
a destination with josh
one of the things that must have been
cool for both of you is that abe wrote
and directed all the scripts all the
episodes and you're not having like
multiple people's visions and voices
sort of coming in but was he very
precious with all the lines on set how
much like you know what i mean like was
he watching the comments or was he sort
of like i want you to make these
characters your own
no he wants
i i think he's very collaborative in
that he definitely in the beginning
process yes i think he i think very open
to i think with this script with these
scripts
it wasn't a preciousness it was a
desire
it was a specificity that's a great word
it was a specificity about like
the intentions
set up because it paid off in certain
episodes you couldn't really play around
with the language because you everything
it was there for a reason so the real
estate was quite tight you didn't want
to like
blow anything but i would say he's
definitely a director who has a strong
idea of the characters in his head yes
and you definitely which i really enjoy
i love being directed um so i really
loved all of his input and i was
constantly able to annoy him at all
times
you never seem to complain
i i don't want to ruin anything but at
some point there are revelations in this
series and i'm just and and man how can
i say this what was your reaction when
you saw the revelations and what abe was
putting on screen
loved loved i'm you know love the way he
tackles it in an old school way
um and
there's just you know again i don't want
to get into any details
but there's
you have to have a certain confidence to
tell a story like this and
not blink not flinch
and that's abe is yeah he's courageous
he's courageous he had a vision from the
beginning
and the execution of that vision
is just him pouring his heart and soul
into
you know doing something so unexpected
and so
crazy
and yet it's all set up in a beautiful
way and it all works i think in a way
that he sticks the landing
uh i'm curious if he said anything to
you assuming that the show is a hit um
about future seasons and where it might
go have you had those conversations with
him about what he envisioned
we haven't been talking yes we can we
can't really talk about anything
yes but but but look if if audiences you
hope with anything audiences were
embracing and if if they do i think that
there's always more story to be told
with such rich characters and also just
i would love to work with josh and abe
again i would feel completely uh
disappointed if we don't get to work
together again
um before i run out of time i just want
to as josh knows i'm a huge fan of
central park um which is on a competing
streamer but i want to know where you
are uh at in the production what can you
tease people
just finished season three
uh the second part of season two is
going to premiere very soon i can't give
the date away yet uh but season three
which we are
in the midst of going into
post-production on
is the best season of television i've
ever been a part of in terms of
storytelling our our show runners uh
calvin and steven
have up the ante and we are
hey we're here to sell wolf
like in an animated space um
and and i think people are going to be
blown away by the music by the story by
the characters it's other than wolf like
me the the best uh
josh got me hooked on it he was like
watch my show i was like what i didn't
know it existed and then i was like
straight in
my question for you is how come he
hasn't put you on the series yet or have
you been added i can't sing
unfortunately we've talked about it yeah
she said i don't want to do that because
i don't like to sing
i don't like to open my mind i would
like to be a fan
i'm going to be from the they don't have
recording booths in perth
right yeah exactly he's very hot right
now yeah
are you really
my last thing for both of you obviously
this series will not work without the
the i don't know the actor's name i
apologize though
yeah
exactly um can you sort of talk a little
bit about working with her because she
is
integral in making all of this work if
you don't buy into her performance
she's a revelation i i
she's also a very special kid yeah she
has a she has she's like a magical
unicorn yes she has a wiseness beyond
her years
there was only one other time where i
ever worked with a young
would-be leading lady where i ever felt
this way and that was emma stone when we
did the rocker where it was just like
there's something very different about
you you're
you are other worldly other world she's
present in a in a in a she's present and
grounded in every moment and she just
it's she's phenomenal yeah
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say i really am looking forward
to people talking about this and being
able to talk about this
thank you for giving me your time great
to see you steven zoe thank you later
you